this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by the cash app you will
already know the cash app is the number
one app in finance but did you realize
you can get the most powerful debit card
in the world with the cash apps cash
card just select a boost in your cash
app swipe the cash card and save 10% or
more at Whole Foods Shake Shack Chipotle
Taco Bell chick-fil-a and all coffee
shops around the country we'll talk
about this more later on this show
download the cash app for free on the
App Store or Google Play market this is
episode 99 we got one more episode to a
hundred and that's this episode and
that's [ __ ] awesome man
we are we're we're we got some you know
it feels like every few episodes we're
still figuring this out and we got new
we got new [ __ ] going on which we got a
new studio right now as you can tell I'm
not in the corner anymore we like it a
little better
and so we moved to a new studio and it's
[ __ ] awesome now it's a little echoey
still because we didn't put all of the
sound padding on yet but we are we are
we are gonna have that before next week
also one fire can you have the time of
that how long I've been doing on the
thing monitor right there so I know oh
that's that's total okay cool alright so
yeah so we're in a new studio and I'm
excited about it and this is the 99th
episode and for the hundredth episode we
have a surprise for you guys and the
also for the 99th episode I figured with
the new studio and everything like that
I would wear my infamous orange shirt
that I talked about on incorrigible so
if you are just listening to the audio
you can watch the YouTube clip and see
the orange shirt that the
girl made called pink that is definitely
orange without a doubt if you haven't
seen it yet but I do wear from time to
time so maybe you do know it now I
spelled coffee now did I split now am I
wearing my [ __ ] shoes that are the
off-white Blazers that are orange to
match it yeah now did I get coffee
earlier yeah did I tell them to not put
room in the coffee by mistake even
though I said put room in the coffee
even though I thought about putting room
in the coffee yeah was it my fault yeah
do I want to blame the barista yeah did
I pour it out yeah
did it splatter back onto my [ __ ]
shoes that are really expensive but hard
to get yeah did it make me angry
yes did that stop it from do the parkas
no I'm here I'm here my babies
the shoes are a little bit like vinyl or
something I don't know what the material
is so I got to wipe it all off are these
problems that are in the first world yes
does it matter as my reality is my
reality so so that's what's up one time
I was complaining about something and
Bobby Lee goes like this he says do you
understand the [ __ ] you're complaining
about people are starving and people are
dying and I said hey man all problems
are relative you know I mean and I was
with David often he was on my side so we
were against Bobby and ever since then
we've been a bit against Bobby now I
also did the tiger belly podcast that's
coming out in the first and in January
we got new merch that doesn't make a
dent
we got the babies it's within the we got
the babies hoodies and the babies a
t-shirt in the Brinks trunk Brinks truck
font so it's on you put that [ __ ]
shirt on and you know that these
[ __ ] know that you are backing
it up you're backing it the [ __ ] up and
it doesn't make a [ __ ] dent dude it
doesn't make a [ __ ] dent because
you're backing it up imagine wearing
that doesn't make the wouldn't make a
dent shirt under the [ __ ] baby's
hoodie what it wouldn't make a dent
they know dude if someone's like oh are
you a baby or you're obviously baby got
the hoodie on and then they take it off
and they go oh but it also wouldn't make
a dent I've been doing a lot of shows in
Los Angeles because I've been haven't
been having fun with material and so I'm
out there doing my [ __ ] and I've been
started to talk about a little bit more
new that I have some newer material I
have a new bit that I'm very excited
about now when you're a comedian and you
got a new bit that you're excited about
that is priceless dude when you're a
comedian you got a new bit you start you
set about there's nothing better than
that man for real you know what it's
also if you think about it it's worth I
mean it's not priceless but it's worth
thousands of dollars to if you have five
minutes of material that's worth
thousands of dollars to a comedian
that's crazy and you could just [ __ ]
be sitting out around at a coffee shop
or just be [ __ ] in bed and just come
up with the bit and you're like dude
that just held me back it the [ __ ] up
dude babies unite so anyway what
whatever the [ __ ] dude I don't know I
was on Instagram and I was watching some
[ __ ] idiots story and she was like
she was like how do you like what what
temperature do you like your hot tub and
it was and you could vote and it said
hot very hot imagine first of all
imagine thinking that and putting that
on as content and then also beyond that
imagine being a [ __ ] guy who votes on
it imagine being a guy who votes on that
[ __ ]
that's just like well I like it very hot
so I guess I'll just vote I mean [ __ ] it
I know it's silly but even if you were
doing it ironically if you're doing it
ironically you're still doing it
that if you got a [ __ ] ironic
mustache guess what you still got that
[ __ ] mustache because you only own
50% of what the [ __ ] is going on anyway
you can do whatever you want my old
writing teacher my old English teacher
used to tell me that I wrote a script
and I sent it to him after I wrote it
after I sent after I graduated high
school I wrote a script I sent it to him
and he really liked it just so you know
babies but also he said you know you
only own 50% 50% of what you write
because 50% of it belongs to the reader
after you're done and I was like wow
he's right and I think about that all
the time that's what that is dude when I
[ __ ] move the thing one fire it
[ __ ] good and now you know what it
[ __ ] sounds like in my ears every
time because we got new headphones we
got new headphones dude we got new
headphones that we got a new [ __ ]
input and everybody's plugged in and
we're all having a great time dude this
is [ __ ] amaze I feel like I can't
scream cuz it's echoey and that's bad
and we got to change that because we
know we scream in this podcast we know
you scream in this podcast so anyway
yeah so you know do you like your
[ __ ] hot tub hot or not it's like
yeah you like it [ __ ] hot it's a hot
tub
not content post [ __ ] when you're when
you just post [ __ ] when you [ __ ]
don't force yourself that's the thing
man these vine [ __ ] they'd be
like we've got to make a vine today no
you don't relax if you're gonna do a
think of it have that [ __ ] thousand
dollar idea okay there we go that's
worth [ __ ] thousands don't be like HM
what do I do now if you could although
[ __ ] what do I know it's your job it's
your job now people are making [ __ ]
thousands of dollars off of being a
social media presence one time I asked a
girl I was like what do you do and she
said I'm an influencer and I was like
woah she just [ __ ] said that [ __ ] man
she just straight-up [ __ ] said it now
granted she was probably 22 but she just
came out the gate said it like she was a
[ __ ] baker or a police officer hey
what do you do I'm an influencer hey
what do you do oh dude I own a pizza
shop what do you do I'm a lawyer
what do you do I'm an influencer and I'm
not betting my I'm not batting my
eyelids because that's what I do and
that's the thing okay
well that's [ __ ] amazing and I've got
one thing to say to that and its head
because you're a [ __ ] the influencer
they got to think of a different name
for that by the way they shouldn't call
it influencer they should call it a
Magus or other are other names for it
like social media person uh but
influencer sounds so [ __ ] [ __ ] I
influence like woody it you might as
well call yourself [ __ ] the Lord the
Lord of social media you might as well
call yourself a lord of social media I'm
a lord in social media by the way what
do you do I'm a lord in social media I'm
an influencer I influence masses that's
what it think I think about when someone
says you're an info I'm an influencer
imagine if you said imagine before
social media if someone's like what did
you do and you're like I'm an influencer
hey you'd be like oh that guy's the
[ __ ] supreme [ __ ]
but now we just live in a world where
you can say I'm an influencer and people
are like okay cool bro when that word
first came out I [ __ ] I [ __ ] on it
mentally come on dude um so anyway we're
off live I was on live I was live on my
[ __ ] app for a while and that's it
dude
you got it if you want to get my app on
the [ __ ] thing you would listen to
watch the first 10 minutes of the
episode before anyone else you do it if
you don't you don't freak conch but if
you want to do it true babe dude that's
it I'm got [ __ ] pocket you know I
that's the thing I decided to do a lot
of podcasts and I decided to do a lot of
shows in town in the Los Angeles and now
I'm like so like podcast it out I'm
going on Ron Funches podcasting a little
bit I got the [ __ ] tiger belly
podcast I'm going on fighter in the kid
again
and it's just at and it's just like I'm
I don't want to do it people do people
come III looked at this [ __ ] this guy
direct messaged me recently and and you
know how you have the direct messages
and then you can go into the secret
direct messages of people that don't
follow you or that you don't follow and
you're like oh there's a bunch of direct
messages that I didn't know about you
can you can so I got a direct message
that and I got a little bitter I got a
red dot on the upper right thing and I
was like oh this is from somebody that
I've either checked a message from
before or somebody I follow and it was
some comedian that had like you know not
a just like a starting up comedian and
he was like hey man I've got a show in
Irvine or some [ __ ] and then also in in
Burbank if you ever want to come by and
do and didn't drop in and do a spot ah
no dude I always say this to my [ __ ]
opener and and he he gets it to it
but some of these young comedians don't
get it you you know it's fine it's fine
once in person or something like yeah I
got a show if you ever want to drop by
oh cool thanks and that's it though but
like you can't ask like there's this guy
who texts me I don't even know how
there's my number I guess I gave it to
him I mean I definitely gave it to him
but he's a comedian he puts on his show
and he's like he's like hey he keeps
texting me if you want come by it's a
show in this [ __ ] it's not like The
Improv side room you know they're in the
Hollywood improv there's the main room
and there's the side room that I never
want to play because it's got [ __ ]
ten tables and chairs in it and their
and and and I don't know why I would
play that because some people like will
maybe want to work on material oh if I
want to work on material I'll do it in
the main room or I'll do it at the
Comedy Store or I'll do it at the Laugh
Factory or I'll do it in my goddamn head
to my dogs but like
I don't know what they think it's like I
guess this sounds maybe pompous or like
cocky but like don't ask it so anyway
the guy was texting me hey you want to
do my show hey just letting you know you
want to do my show he kept text me I
wasn't texting back because I'm like
well I don't want to do that [ __ ]
room and then also like I'm doing other
shows those nights and also by the way
getting paid you know and then and then
he [ __ ] so if I'm ignoring your text
from that then then then he came up to
me in real life and was like hey man
what are you doing some date and I was
like oh what's up and he was like hey uh
what do you do you want to come do my
show and I said hey where is it and he
said oh it's in the it's at the improv I
said is it in that little room and he
said yeah I said yeah I don't want to do
a show in that room I hate that room and
it's like whoa whoa and now I gotta be a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
I don't know dude I don't know it's like
if you're gonna ask a girl out you know
and you text her twice or three times
that's too much if she's gonna get back
to you if she wants but then if you see
her somewhere and you're like hey what's
up hey I've been texting you did you
want to go out like do you understand
how you're coming across which here's
the other thing too if you're a comedian
the number one thing you need arguably
is self-awareness if you don't know how
you're coming across to one guy how are
you going to know you're coming how
you're coming across to a room full of
350 people that want to see [ __ ]
comedy like some of these instances some
of these comedians they think they're
you know I mean some of these kamini
there's a few comedians I follow and
some that I don't just because I can't
but it's just like you posting pictures
you think you're a [ __ ] model and
some of them are friends of mine and I
give it to him you know I [ __ ] make
fun of them but like some of you guys
like they dress up in like dope some of
them one guy I know some one guy is a
model so it's fine
but the
the guy another guy is like a
goofy-looking comedian that like dresses
dapper and he's like hey man he's dead
like in a [ __ ] hanger like were you
taking these pictures man are you a ho
I should say I want to see that guy out
and just be like hey man get get fake
tits man we talked about it well the
pictures are taking is it what do you
mean oh you're taking pictures in a
hanger
what do you mean what do I mean get fake
tits he's a bull but no I'm a comedian
oh oh you know what I got confused
because when I looked at some of your
pictures online
you're in a hanger if you're in a hanger
be a hooker or an airplane all right
guess what I'm never doing hanging out
in a hanger dude unless I'm getting on a
[ __ ] plane okay that's it case closed
my husband Todd in that movie Copland
best acting me Nero did my husband Todd
now go to lunch my hands are tied my
hands are tied now this acting De Niro
ever did I don't give a [ __ ] talk about
Raging Bull talk about a deer hunter
talk about taxi driver best acting ever
De Niro in Copland my hands are tied now
go to lunch my hands are tied now
there's nothing I can do my head's tied
now best acting of all time period De
Niro period has time now when he said
that forget it I was like uh you know
what forget it De Niro best actor of all
time hasn't died now he did that my
husband now do you know the confidence
you have to have acting to say my hands
are tied now and to do a [ __ ] my
husband ax to do the hands tied cuz it's
so you could so closely be acting badly
that's the thing
he turned bad acting on its [ __ ] ass
like I say dude we're always one step
where it's a circle everything's a
circle I [ __ ] say this all the time
everything
you go from the [ __ ] you're the [ __ ]
right here if you're looking on the
video podcast and then you get away from
in the [ __ ] you get away from being this
[ __ ] in a circular motion you get away
from either this is the furthest point
from the [ __ ] and you keep going but
it's a life you were to put that circle
out on the line you go the [ __ ] all the
way not to the [ __ ] right so now you go
you [ __ ] you make that line a circle
dude I'm a professor you make that line
a circle and you turn it around like
that this is the furthest point from
being the [ __ ] but it's the closest
point to be in the [ __ ] dude that's what
[ __ ] DeNiro did with acting
he went bad acting my husband Todd now
imagine a [ __ ] like you know I mean
dude like a play in like a [ __ ] play
where there it is right there
video my house it's odd now I gotta play
it dude what where's the [ __ ] I mean
the way he does it dude it's Sid the
Niro do it let's go on YouTube here
I got a play for the pocket no internet
cool I'm angry we didn't start it we
didn't do it and now on fire I'm angry
yeah no I know that
Copland scene okay I'm doing it now here
we go babies do it but he imagine like a
play in in like a like we've all seen
like high school plays or some [ __ ] or
like horrible plays where it's like
imagine somebody saying my hands are
tied now and they're doing their two
hands tied it will be horrible it will
be [ __ ] horrible
and that's what DeNiro did only he did
it in the good way you just wrote in
Copland scene and that's what came up
Jesus that's amazing
well that's amazing you came to me to my
town all these speeches you taught us
the loan is talking about doing the
right thing then here what's going on
what are you doing oh he's eating okay
all right all right look all right look
dude
the Neuros eating a sandwich in this
[ __ ] scene that's how good of an
actor he is I apply have a sandwich or
something you know put a sandwich down
here and then it was they were like okay
well let's get him a sandwich
cuz he was in Copland you know he's like
I'm doing you a favor [ __ ] you put a
sandwich down here I'm gonna eat it
we're gonna do it about three times I
don't wanna get too full and they're
like all right I guarantee you he did
this [ __ ] twice two weeks ago he the
way he's eating this [ __ ] two weeks
ago V nobody's been more matter-of-fact
in their life then de niro eating this
sandwich right now it shows how much he
doesn't give a [ __ ] about Stallone not
the character Stallone he's like I'm
NATIVE sandwich songs I don't know if
you James you know is that company the
[ __ ] sandwich you know I'm in this
movie this is your movie you know this
is a good movie for you for me it's
nothing
Wow the other guy oh and by the way the
other guy who's from that [ __ ] what
was that move was at that old show NYPD
blue or some [ __ ] some-some show like
that not in Hawaii PD blue but there's
another character standing off to the
side of the Nero he's eating a [ __ ]
donut and that was De Niro's idea - no
doubt he was like I'm not gonna sit here
and not this guy's gotta eat - I'm not
gonna do this [ __ ] movie unless he
eats - I want everyone eating sandwiches
except Stallone except Stallone cuz
we're all against Spallone he didn't
even explain it but that's in his head
he's like we're all against the one we
gotta be eaten that's sewed dude that's
a real real [ __ ] boss move wow you
got to think you gotta [ __ ] keep that
in you mentally babies if you want to
pull a boss move on somebody you [ __ ]
get everybody in the room eating
sandwiches except the one guy you want
to pull the boss move on god damn that's
a [ __ ] book we all you know we learn
things we learn things every day and
that's one of them right now
we you want to pull the biggest boss
move you [ __ ] eat a bunch of
sandwiches and you don't have one guy
eat the sandwiches that you're talking
to
and you know I'm right what about
Babbage here we go what about [ __ ] him
there we go [ __ ] yeah add living by the
way not even in this window fall off a
building
surely the papers didn't wasn't part of
it made it up for local building this
exercise I'm really sorry to have awoken
you from your slumber but it's over from
your slumber but it's over hands are
tied now you shut me now oh I forgot
about this part and you blew it
so DeNiro in three two one Wow
you know he's eating tuna - just to say
[ __ ] you just alone best acting I've
ever seen in my life
best acting I've ever seen in my life in
my whole life dude my hands are tied now
and he stands up I offered you it I
offered you a chance to be a cop and you
blow it amazing girls when you have sex
with your next guy and they after they
have set after they bus tonight you got
to say you'll blow it you blow it and if
they're kinky and they like to tie you
up you say my hands by now ah
wow so dumb it's hot my babies
it's [ __ ] steaming hot in this room
we're getting the kinks out okay we're
gonna do there we go
post mates as usual your stomach and the
rest of your life rat war you need to
eat but you can't stop what you're doing
to deal with it and the only fast things
that deliver are not what you want
introducing post mates the app that adds
a delivery option to your favorite rest
imagine anything you want to eat
delivered you don't have to drive park
or even talk on the phone to order just
download the app and order 24 hours a
day 365 days a year
post mates will bring what you want post
mates will bring you what you want
within the hour
you can even see where your food is and
track your driver which is very cool I
use it all the time I check it all the
time Gau CD you forgot to get eggs and
milk no problem you craving a tasty
burger got it a bottle of red wine or
summer beer you got it you just do it
these go on post mates for a limited
time post mates is giving you a $100 off
free delivery credit for your first 7
days to start your free deliveries
download the app today and use code
Congrats
that's code congrats for $100 of free
delivery credit for your first 7 days
save the hassle get the food you love
fast at post mates with code Congrats so
many typos on that one Robin Hood so
Robin Hood is an investing app that lets
you buy and sell stocks ETFs options and
Kryptos all commission free other
brokerages charge up to $10 for every
trade but Robin Hood doesn't charge
Commission fees trade stocks and keep
all of your profits it's that easy to
understand so they make these charts
really easy and market data there's a
place to trade in just 4 taps on your
smart phone Robin Hood web platform also
lets you view stock collections 100 most
popular sectors like entertainment and
social media and curated categories like
female CEOs and analysts ratings of buy
hold sell for every stock learn by doing
learn how to invest as you build your
portfolio discover new stocks and track
favorite companies with personalized
news feed
custom notifications for price movements
so you never miss the right movement to
invest I liked and you know the way the
app is designed is very
it's very easy to user friendly and I
learn if I can learn by doing you can
but it's cool Robin Hood is giving a
listener is giving listeners a free
stock like Apple Ford or Sprint to help
build your portfolio sign up at congrats
dot Robin Hood calm that's Congrats
Robin Hood calm yeah you blew it but but
it's over hands are tied now you shut me
down no no listen to me your ia that's
why I came to you can do whatever you
want member you came to me said you want
to be a cop I'm being a good now I'm
here I need to do it socially I need to
do this [ __ ] we could have done
something I offered you a chance to be a
cop and you blow it
oh wow I could listen to that all day
somebody's gotta make some music with
that um I also see like by the way those
[ __ ] like whose if I I think I've
taught I've talked about this before
here's the deal if you do the QA things
on Instagram like that the story thing
it's so [ __ ] also everyone does it
like this
hey I'm are I'm at the airport I'm bored
why don't I do this no do it because a
self-centered egotistical and that's it
freak hunch do it if you want but don't
act like now I might as well do this
[ __ ] now huh waiting for my pizza Wow
might as well ask some questions go
ahead ask away
I saw his chick with some [ __ ] fake
tits and she's and some guys like what's
your dream guy has to have
sense of humor has to be driven one
chicks sake dudes have to have a sense
of humor you know we're so ridiculous
people are [ __ ] boring huh like just
straight up people are just so boring
how about how that Copland movie clip
has a hundred and twenty four thousand
views the [ __ ] looking up that scene
that's crazy weird to me but don't ya
don't we got to stop we got to fight
this [ __ ] CUDA [ __ ] where you're just
pretending be you who you are and it's
fine you don't have to [ __ ] fake it
and pretend just [ __ ] be who you are
and that's fine
hey I'm a glutton for [ __ ] attention
ask me questions that's it we can't be
like my hands are tied now I'm [ __ ]
you know I'm waiting for a pizza how
about one something when [ __ ] people
from the East Coast put in our at the
end of pizza that's unbelievable
hey you want to get a pizza oh there's
no R at the end of it I got an idea oh
but it's idea IDE egg I got an idea
let's get a pizza hey I got an idea you
want a pacer hey are you a [ __ ]
lunatic um my buddy my buddy Brendan
Schaub went on first of all somebody get
Brendan Schaub to stop [ __ ] posting
pictures of Porsches with Christmas
trees on top of them Thanks
second of all uh yeah he was on Logan
Paul's podcast impulsive and everyone is
first of all everyone everyone is
hitting me up like hey your boy what are
your thoughts like dude this isn't I'm
not a [ __ ] you know I mean this isn't
news
okay just he can go on the pockets if
you want
and people are like oh dude you [ __ ]
up Brandon why you why you going on a
podcast look first of all I listened to
almost
oh I let's do a lot of it I thought say
at least half because I wanted to hear
it and Logan's been asking me to go on
the podcast and I've been thinking about
it you know I mean I'm [ __ ] never in
town now but and yeah he reached out to
me or something or you know what
happened Logan posted on his timeline
that he was laughing at my mmm
impression and so I was like oh my god
that's cool it's like you know cuz like
here's the thing man if if you're in a
Twitter roast thing with somebody like
I'll tell you right now I don't really
give a [ __ ] if somebody's gonna if I'm
just playing with somebody even if I'm
like yo go [ __ ] yourself yada yada like
I don't know the guy so [ __ ] it like how
am I actually angry with somebody that I
don't know really in a personal way it's
I can't be so people who with you know
our fans of mine but don't really get my
humor are like dude you all you hate
[ __ ] Logan Paul which is dude I don't
know I don't know him okay
I've never met him but I listened to the
podcast and with that Brendan was on my
boy Brendan Schaub and if I if that was
the first thing I ever heard of Logan
I'd be like oh this guy seems like a
legit dude he's very self-reflective he
was talking about his you know he's
quick to say oh I [ __ ] up or whatever
and just seems like a regular guy
that's a nice dude and a smart guy at
that I think and that got me to thinking
you know Peter first of all people are
so quick to just bash somebody and you
know what he did it when the suicide
forest was it was a stupid move I've
done stupid [ __ ] I don't know if I've
done something as stupid as that maybe I
have maybe I haven't
a lot of people probably have but this
guy but it got me thinking if you grow
up through YouTube and posting things
and that's your community posting videos
people know of your videos before they
know of you even your friends you post a
video of your fret of e of you I mean
you see it all the time you post an
Instagram that's how you keep up with
your friends but if you're a 35 year old
just getting Instagram you already know
who you are if you're 20 I'm sorry but
you don't know who you are yet I mean
maybe maybe some of you do okay I can't
say all of you but like you know the
brain stops developing when I don't know
I'm not a scientist but I mean you're
holding people accountable for a [ __ ]
that they said when they were 14 which
is not okay because you're not who you
are and then also take into the account
that this kid and a lot of these kids
grew up posting they didn't grew up they
didn't grow up they grew up talking and
conversing with people and but they also
the thing that is charging and leading
their lives is posting and that's not
okay and this is a new thing in our
lives in the world so we're still
learning what the effects are of this we
don't know there's no data you don't
know why somebody we don't really know
why somebody poll you say oh yeah
because you know it's instant
gratification but you don't really know
you don't know who the people are that
log onto Twitter you don't know who the
main what their main drive is to log on
to [ __ ] YouTube you don't know what
their main drive is to log onto onto
Instagram on Instagram so so we're very
quick to just judge somebody to do
something stupid online but you have to
understand this is also a bigger problem
with the whole community with YouTube
with with the people
that RRR it's like when I say you know
you're an idiot for posting a Q&A but
then you're an idiot for [ __ ]
answering and voting so what I'm trying
to say is no I don't hate him
people are like oh we know you hate this
guy are you people even friends of mine
are you guys cool now there's no cooler
not cool I don't know the guy he seems
like a fine guy he actually when I I
don't know anything about him the only
thing I know up I mean I know of him
obviously I know the the posts but and
those YouTube videos they're not for me
but I'm not the demographic they're for
kids so fine he got way too wrapped up
in it did the suicide forest thing that
was a big mistake but watching the the
podcast with Brendan the guy seems like
a [ __ ] guy I you know I don't know I
feel little I felt a little bit bad too
because when I saw Brendan did the
podcast I was like oh wow I was like huh
I said I wonder why he did that because
of all this negative [ __ ] that surrounds
Logan with the suicide forest thing and
then I thought oh well I'm just gonna
look at it and I thought oh these are
two [ __ ] grown men that are having an
adult conversations and nobody's going
to go beyond that thing that they
there's a lot of people and and smart
people are not going to go beyond that
headline of all we filmed a dead body
which is problematic it actually is
problematic because because you know you
get the guy that okay it's like it's
like it's like look at what happens with
Jordan Peterson okay
really smart well-thought-out guy not
all right he's not an alt right guy
people have a visceral response to that
to him because of what he's saying then
they post about it write an article
that's a well-thought-out article of
their visceral response
and then somebody sees the title of that
article doesn't read the article and
thinks wow [ __ ] Jordan Peterson
that's a game of telephone that's [ __ ]
and that's what everybody's doing and
that's a problem so all I'm saying is if
you're a listener of my podcast just try
to get some [ __ ] context here period
when you judge some before you judge
somebody because you don't know and
maybe [ __ ] these guys really are
[ __ ] but do your [ __ ] homework
and find out for yourself read all the
things about it because I think I look
dude I think I think I think I'm a good
person but I've said dumb [ __ ] and if
you take all of the things on this
podcast that I said that are dummy [ __ ]
and clip them all together you're gonna
think I'm a [ __ ] flagrant [ __ ] I
would think that so it's a weird [ __ ]
thing man it's so [ __ ] weird so
basically all I'm saying is
what's the sheriff I'm really sorry to
have awoken you from your slumber but
it's over hands are tied now you shut
that's what I'm saying
from your slumber but it's over hands
are tied well hands are tied now hands
are tied now hands are tied now you shut
me down hands are tied now your hands
are tied now hands up hands are tied now
hands are tied now you shut me down
hands are tied now that's amazing hands
are tied now here's a tide now um yeah I
don't know
we take breaks babies goat if you're
buying sneakers online listen to me if
you're buying sneakers online now this
is true there's more than a coin flips
chance that the shoe you're looking at
is fake how can you be sure it's real go
calm it's the best way to buy and sell a
cell by the way also authentic sneakers
online they're the largest market place
in the world for authentic Easy's
Jordans and over 600,000 sneaker
listings they've made the whole process
frictionless and trustworthy they do
this by only accepting sellers with the
best reputation and by verifying all
sneakers to ensure their authenticity
for buyers every detail is inspected
from the stitching and color to the size
and weight Goat certifies that every
pair of sneakers on their site match is
exactly factory exact factory
specifications with over half a million
sneakers on the platform and 10 million
users you won't find better prices for
verified 100% authentic sneakers
anywhere else find the perfect 100%
authentic sneaker at Goat calm /
Congrats that's Goat calm / congrat
Congrats plus you'll also be supporting
our show but you got to go right now
before the sneakers you want are gone
because that happens and it's s annoying
when you go to go calm / Congrats
you won't have to worry about that so
spelled go8
calm / Congrats Kasia it's a time now
you should time now you should you
already know the cash app is the number
one app in finance but did you realize
you get the most powerful debit card in
the world with cash apps cash card the
cash card comes with boosts a feature
you can't get anywhere else because cash
app invented it just select a boost in
your cash app swipe the cash card and
save 10% or more at Whole Foods Shake
Shack Chipotle Taco Bell chick-fil-a and
all coffee shops around the country the
coffee shop boost takes $1 off at any
coffee shop including Dunkin and
Starbucks drink 100 cups a year save
$100 it's that simple
become a part of the greatest rewards
program ever and download the cash app
now it's the number one app for a reason
and the cash card is the only debit card
with boosts and of course when you
download the cash app and enter referral
code Congrats
you'll receive $5 and the cash app will
send $5 - times up Legal Defense Fund
visit the App Store or Google Play
market and download the cash app hey by
the way what's the deal with I said
Duncan Duncan don't has changed it to
Duncan what's up with I hop i hub did
they let me tell you something I will
never go to IHOP again because of their
[ __ ] [ __ ] stunt about how they
change their name and they didn't
whenever I Drive by [ __ ] I hops I see
a P at the end change it or I'm not
going make it I hub or I'm not going
anymore
and look I don't you know that oh okay
well crystal is not coming to give us a
[ __ ] okay fine neither are the babies
how about that I [ __ ] spoken it's
[ __ ]
man
listen Sheriff I'm really sorry to have
awoken you from your slumber but it's
over hands are tied now you understand
turn it off I hop by the way I forgot to
do that sorry for the ads that we didn't
Ansari guys I gotta catch up on these
for the ads sorry guys
life's good doesn't my back hurt yeah
doesn't my shoulder hurt yeah did did I
do a jump yesterday at the gym and did I
feel my back tighten up and then it I
have to take it easy yeah I'm a 38 yeah
as life good yeah would I pay a hundred
grand for my back and my shoulder not to
hurt ya can I do that now should I have
been born in 20 years when they can
figure out pain probably yeah dude I
think about that [ __ ] all the time
about how like the future needs to catch
up and about how like oh they'll figure
it out when I was a kid I would be like
yeah they'll figure out all the [ __ ]
though by the time I'm 30 they'll have
it all dialed in guess what people still
dying of cancer people are still dying
[Music]
yep you can't cure HIV even though you
can maybe because of Magic Johnson what
the [ __ ] happened there the guy looks
heavy dude old mask nobody looks less
healthy healthy than old basketball
players just moving all around and [ __ ]
like [ __ ] like [ __ ] rock creatures
just old basketball dudes just hobbling
around god they're so tall hey what's
going on uh too tall ah cool
too tall and fifty cool fifty and too
tall dead soon straight up you bought
your whole body Aiken why too tall oh
hey how come I'm as tall as a tree
oh okay cool hey I missed tall as a
redwood so after fifty might as well
kill myself all right cool guess what
I'm gonna do baby it's order food on you
that's how disrespectful I am you think
I give a [ __ ] how about remember when
the guy was not remembering Guinness
Book dude I used to love those Guinness
Book of World Records [ __ ] dude
I used to get him every single year you
submit my parents get him for me and the
guy was nine feet tall
Robert perishing was nine feet tall
lived to be [ __ ] 11 okay see ya dude
if you're 9 foot tall you live to be 11
that's it you cannot live past 11 if
you're nine feet tall yeah he was 22 and
he died at 22 right yeah because you
can't be [ __ ] 9 feet tall so there
you go you can't be [ __ ] 9 feet tall
dude what's the place I order from oh
yeah it's a good restaurant in on
Melrose called the [ __ ] beefsteak
sounds like [ __ ] what do I get
I don't remember haven't gotten in a
while
[Music]
yeah oh they don't have it anymore
I'm postmates Singh baby I'm pause
Manson baby what is this [ __ ]
smoothies guess what I never want a
smoothie
you know why I want to eat all the [ __ ]
as it is I'm not I don't need to [ __ ]
don't grind up all my fruit you know
that's the thing man you're not supposed
to eat that you're not supposed to eat
it that way now granted I processed
sugar because purse but like you know
alright alright alright here we go
okay are we getting kale season we
getting seasonal veggies dude seasonal
veggies just say veggies you know I know
the ones in season because it's this
season and you don't have to be [ __ ]
done then dude don't be [ __ ] done
then anyway let's do some Twitter
questions and then we'll do some
misconnections dude let's do some
misconnections
let's do those first I come on well this
one's the best one I've ever seen okay
so this one's says the tight this title
is the best title I mean it's the better
it's better than [ __ ] the title
Mission Impossible Ghost Protocol
looking for a deep throat car technician
there's something that you never there's
the worst band ever
deep throat car technician thanks for
coming out
we are deep there Karthik
here's the song about love probably I'm
looking for a female deep throating car
technician who can help me out in
downtown LA tomorrow morning or at noon
what the [ __ ] do they mean do not
contact me with unsolicited services
robbers there's for sure somebody you
can contact this is unsolicited services
what is it deep throat car technician do
you need somebody to actually work on
your car or do you just need somebody to
suck your [ __ ] ah I mean what if she's
like I don't know anything about cars
but I'll suck your [ __ ] okay now I dude
yeah I mean I'd love to but I really
need my car worked on to like well what
talk about kill two birds with one stone
hey do you got anybody couldn't suck my
[ __ ] but also fix my [ __ ] car burn a
carburetor is that the other thing what
is it
carburetor carburetor it makes soda a
manly bro carbonator dude that's how
that's the guy by the way ha
he just needs a bj but he's like ya know
but I also I need a carbon I need to fix
my carbonator but oh by the way because
we're a bj in it how about this one this
is Milo this one the fact that okay 69
[ __ ] socket
today at Los Angeles with an exclamation
point like 69 [ __ ] suck today at Los
Angeles uh first of all done dn't
you don't need to say [ __ ] sucked if
you're 69 and he puts things in our
first cos you were scrolling 469 si
we'll wait what's going on
69 [ __ ] suck today at Lausanne
Julis why am I like this you know that
meme 69 cocksuck car technician why am I
like this I'm in loss it make it bigger
I'm in Los Angeles for the day oh man
like how it's just I'm not not where I
usually am just looking for a 69
[ __ ]
I'm looking to meet up with someone the
city and water I mean this guy do you
guys know English I'm in Los Angeles for
the day I'm looking to meet up someone
the city and want us some discreet fun
with I'm an attractive 29 year old 29
year white female 5 6 love give and
receiving oral and also love to some
clean [ __ ] in hotel room Hey I mean
figure it out
if anybody interested ask me anything
please text me now sucker mom 36 what
please text me now sucker mom 36 hey at
80 G+ question mark I don't know Malou I
host please put the subject cocksuck in
reply this person is dirty as [ __ ]
thank you all he's polite at the end
she's polite you know go down oh you can
solicit this person with [ __ ]
anything unsolicited goes also you can
hit up this person if you don't you want
them to like fix your carbonator or
something up no sorry do not contact me
with unsolicited way down there what is
all that [ __ ] that they're writing so
it's searching
oh and then by the way there's something
down there that says looking for cello
players at all levels hey babies in
tuxedos lol why does it say that for no
reason it just as babies in tuxedos lol
maybe that means podcast listeners okay
see ya
this one gets right to the point seeking
blonde milf with big titties I am a 31
year old male who is looking for a hot
blonde milf cougar type with huge
titties what's wrong with this world I
am oh wow dude I am open to all
positions do not contact me unsolicited
services or offers like by the way what
does that mean all positions I guess
you're on top me but you want to do some
doggy I'm down you want to do the
Republican I'm down you want to do the
wheelbarrow while I hold your ankles and
you [ __ ] are on your palms
God how boring on are you if you're
doing interesting sexual positions just
there's three I've said this before you
do you do on top you get you do her on
top you do doggy or you do the
Republican which is the side laying down
dog you're the lazy doggy I call it the
Republican because your Republican is
[ __ ] if you're doing that a Democrat has
never done that here we go what are you
laughing at this one just what I'm
saying like a [ __ ] bore you literally
have your red tie on while you're doing
the [ __ ] side doggy how lazy are you
if your [ __ ] doggy style and you're
like yeah actually let's lay on our left
side I need to straighten out my legs
they're cramping here's another one and
then we'll get off to Twitter questions
maybe looking for a snack torence
first of all way to use uh today's
jargon today's hot language looking for
a snack I hate that [ __ ] whole snacks a
yeah
just been in a slump yeah no [ __ ] man
you're on Craigslist looking for a snack
oh you're on a slump no looking for a
snack just been in a slump want to
interact with a woman a sad sad interact
is the saddest word just been in a slump
want to interact with a woman by the way
interacting with someone is hey how you
doing and that's it also that's sad
imagine imagine getting a [ __ ]
imagine your dick going horizontal for
that want to once measure dick on
perpendicular get to use cute words cuz
you laze I'm fluffy and down to have a
snack let's chat and maybe chill do not
contact me with unsolicited service or
offers I actually believe that from this
guy cuz this guy sounds like he's just
lonely and wants to just kick it wow
what is that one
god these [ __ ] things are amazing la
tin bro home alone second Street
discrete Latin or old guy looking for
buds to come over and relax no pressure
very oral guy here Jack BJ play by car
uh-oh play by ear it's too far away Jack
that's great just no [ __ ] punctuation
at all very very oral guy here Jack BJ
play by ear uh-huh very oral guy here
Jack BJ play by ear straight bi no drama
guys serious pic stats for now now
serious only for now now he wants it now
bro alright let's go to Twitter
questions do we have any good ones
no you babies didn't come through make
it bigger
oh that's a good one
b5 at beef ff5 I don't know Chris Thalia
act Congrats pot thoughts about guys who
unbutton and buckle their pants yeah
like you leave the buckle on but you
just unzip and let your [ __ ] dick out
too and pull down their underwear at the
urinal instead of unzipping and using
the flap on their me undies yeah you're
talking about a guy that leaves it
buckled and just takes their dick out to
piss those guys you can't trust that's
so weird
it's extra work you think you're
unzipping your fly you know I don't have
to unbuckle alright but those guys they
have no time management skills they
think it's easier to just unzip and let
the [ __ ] out it's not it's more work you
got to [ __ ] hold the belt and unzip
and then reach in like you're trying to
[ __ ] pick a lemon and pull your [ __ ]
out and the zipper by the way shreds the
layer of skin on your [ __ ]
I'm sensitive babies so that's [ __ ]
if you just if you if you look like you
just have your pants on period from
behind when you're pissing at a urinal
you can't nah
get with the program and just pull your
pants down now
I've seen a guy take his pants all the
way down it is if you got your pants
down at your ankles at the urinal you
deserve to get [ __ ] in the butt
straight up right there you deserve to
get [ __ ] in the butt and if it happens
that's your fault that's on you dude you
deserve to get [ __ ] pumped right you
but you know you try to not get [ __ ]
in the butt but you blow it okay Austin
Lopez at Austin's dolphins change it
crystally chrisley what's the most
amount of pounds you'd pack on for a
role before that's the kind of
[ __ ] I am for prosthetics hey
music can put me in a fat suit this
Christian Bale [ __ ]
I love Christian Bale but also a part of
me wants to be like hey act these hot
actresses that are like I need to get
into it I'm gonna play someone ugly hey
act oh you put a hook nose on cuz you're
trying to get an Oscar scene through yet
the baby see through you the baby see
through that four pounds I don't know
man I would get fit for a role if I need
to hold a gun and [ __ ] shoot some
[ __ ]
I'd get fit for a role but get fat it's
I don't know maybe I don't know I shaved
my head but do what Christian Bale did
in the most respectful thing I've done
on this podcast to date is just yawn
like I'm just chilling with you guys
like you're in a room thank you very
much anyway
yeah so that's good that's it that's
good we're good
four pounds download the cash app for
free on the App Store or Google Play
market enter rewards code congrats get
five dollars give five dollars - times
up and the episode 100 episode 100 is
coming on Christmas Eve and it is
there's a special thing it's gonna be a
different format and I just want you
guys to know that and it's going to be
awesome we are going we are going to
have our first guest our first guest
and it's our 100 episode so stay tuned
for that
follow the leader dates on web on my
website buy tickets as Christmas gifts
babies I'm going to so many different
cities download the crystal eeeh a pew
don't watch the first 10 minutes of the
podcast live and chat with other babies
on there subscribe to the YouTube
channel please rate and review our show
it really helps us videos go up
Tuesday's or wednesdays dates coming up
San Antonio Louisville Kentucky Austin
Indianapolis st. Louis so get your
tickets there and and that's it ran and
remember I have the platinum
[Music]